[Aplausos]
[Música]
os voy a contar una historia y quiero
que penséis si este caso es real o no es
más que un cuento de ciencia ficción
esto es una ciudad importante de cientos
de miles de habitantes que se encuentra
enclavada en una bahía
en un día de niebla densa aparece de
repente y sigilosamente un barco oculto
entre la densidad de la niebla
entonces con un cañón dispersor de
aerosoles este barco empieza a expulsar
algo extraño al aire
y resulta que eso que están dispersando
no son ni más ni menos que bacterias
fin de la historia se trata de lo real o
no
pues amigos esto que os estoy contando
no es el comienzo de ninguna película de
ciencia ficción ni de ningún experimento
perverso del doctor mengele os estoy
contando algo que realmente ocurrió en
el año 1950 ni más ni menos que en la
ciudad de san francisco en los eeuu
el ejército de los eeuu dispersos sobre
san francisco no una vez sino al menos
seis veces las bacterias bacillus
subtilis y serratia marcescens sin que
por supuesto la población de la ciudad
lo supiera
en ese momento estas bacterias se
consideraban no dañinas para el ser
humano sin embargo este experimento
causó al menos el fallecimiento de una
persona y la hospitalización de otras 10
además en el caso de la bacteria
serratia marcescens se terminó
demostrando que si era perjudicial para
la salud y el uso de experimentos de
este tipo favoreció que a día de hoy
esta bacteria sea muy resistente a los
antibióticos y se suelen producir brotes
serios con cierta frecuencia
llegados a este punto seguro seguro que
ahora muchos os estáis haciendo una
pregunta por qué demonios los eeuu
decidieron fumigar con bacterias a su
propia población qué interés tenían pues
amigos la clave la encontramos en el
programa de armas biológicas que los
eeuu pusieron en marcha en el año 1943 y
por el cual durante al menos 20 años
entre el 49 y el 69 se realizaron
pruebas de gérmenes con fines de guerra
pruebas que se llegaron a realizar sobre
ciudades utilizando como cobayas a la
población civil sí sí como cobayas ahora
bien no no penséis ni por un instante
que fueron ni los primeros ni los
últimos ni los pioneros y es algo que
existe desde hace muchos muchísimos años
[Aplausos]
queréis saber más sobre el despiadado
mundo de las armas biológicas y la
amenaza que realmente pueden llegar a
suponer creéis que en el mundo de hoy
estamos preparados para enfrentarnos a
un posible ataque biológico atentos bio
armas la historia militar más turbia
antes de empezar con esta historia un
motivo de alivio el desarrollo y la
experimentación con armas biológicas
están prohibidos desde 1975 por la
convención sobre la prohibición del
desarrollo la producción y el
almacenamiento de armas biológicas y
tóxicas y sobre su destrucción que es
como se llama este acuerdo
[Música]
en fin en la práctica la inmensa mayoría
de los países del mundo han dejado de
desarrollar y experimentar con ellas
pero hasta entonces hubo varios países
que desarrollaron e incluso en algunos
casos utilizaron con cierta frecuencia
este tipo de armas hablamos sobre todo
de eeuu la unión soviética y japón
[Música]
pero no fueron pioneros e incluso mucho
antes de que estas potencias pusieran en
marcha sus planes de desarrollo
biológicos con fines militares claro las
armas biológicas ya tenían una larga
historia
los primeros planes de armas biológicas
datan de al menos el siglo 16 antes de
cristo con los hititas asimismo existen
pruebas de su uso habitual ya en el
siglo 4 antes de cristo cuando los
escitas lanzaban flechas envenenadas a
sus enemigos y no sólo eso se sabe
también que era frecuente que persas
griegos y romanos envenenarán los pozos
y las fuentes de agua de sus enemigos
con personas y animales fallecidos por
enfermedades contagiosas algo parecido a
lo que hacían los tártaros en el siglo
14 que directamente lanzaron cuerpos con
pestes sobre los genoveses en caza o
también por ejemplo los británicos en el
siglo 18 que infectaban mantas con
viruela y se las daban a los indios
norteamericanos
pero por supuesto no tenemos que irnos
tan atrás en el tiempo para observar un
uso frecuente de armas biológicas sin ir
más lejos japón utilizó ampliamente
armas de este tipo durante la primera
mitad del siglo 20
el imperio de japón tenía incluso un
escuadrón específico el 7 31 para
investigar en prisioneros vivos los
efectos de ciertas bacterias y virus
patógenos que luego fueron usados
indiscriminadamente durante las campañas
de invasión de asia
por ejemplo en el año 1939 japón empleó
la bacteria salmonella typhi para
contaminar embalses de agua de la
antigua unión soviética
de hecho es por este pasado por este
auge de las armas biológicas por los que
eeuu establecieron su propio programa en
1943 en plena guerra mundial un programa
que se mantuvo activo durante décadas y
que a día de hoy ha hecho que la
potencia norteamericana se sitúe como el
país más avanzado en tecnología de
guerra biológica
ahora bien la pregunta es a qué precio
como lo consiguieron pues bien agarramos
a la silla porque aquí hay mucha tela
que cortar y sabéis me atrevo a decir
que no os va a dejar indiferentes si la
historia de san francisco que os
contamos al principio este vídeo ya os
sorprendió lo que viene a continuación
es aún peor atentos
[Música]
ciudadanos o cobayas de laboratorio
amigos lo de san francisco no fue ni
mucho menos una idea de hoya puntual las
pruebas de armas biológicas de eeuu
fueron relativamente frecuentes durante
años el objetivo principal de estas
pruebas era comprender el alcance sobre
la población y la propagación de daños
que podría tener el ataque biológico de
un enemigo de un grupo terrorista y el
caso es que para avanzar en esas
investigaciones el ejército de los eeuu
líbero bacterias que se consideraban
inocuas o poco dañinas lo que se conoce
como agentes de reemplazo a veces
también junto a productos químicos y
después se analizaba el aire para
comprender hasta dónde y en qué
concentración se expandía
sin embargo lamentablemente no siempre
esas pruebas estadounidenses fueron tan
quirúrgicas tan precisas fijaos
por ejemplo durante los años 1957 y 1958
el ejército de los eeuu voló a aviones a
baja altura en zonas como san luís o
minnesota lanzando sobre zonas urbanas
una mezcla de sulfuro de cadmio y
sulfuro de zinc y para los que no lo
sepáis el cadmio es tóxico y cancerígeno
el caso es que estos experimentos se
llevaron a cabo sobre población civil
completamente inadvertida se realizaron
fundamentalmente sobre barrios de
minorías negras y de baja renta
[Música]
marín servilista soles narcos touring
pero eso no es todo en diferentes
lugares del país experimentos similares
tuvieron lugar hasta el año 1968 queréis
saber las consecuencias años más tarde
varios estudios observaron un aumento en
la incidencia de diversos tipos de
cáncer en las zonas donde se llevaron a
cabo estos experimentos
y no os perdáis lo mejor lo que le decía
el gobierno de eeuu a la gente era
básicamente que esos aviones que
lanzaban una nube de algo extraño
estaban realizando en realidad un
experimento para cubrir esas ciudades
con una especie de niebla que permitiría
ocultarlas ante un ataque aéreo madre
mía quién demonios se le ocurre fumigar
desde aviones a la población civil y
solo para hacer un experimento de locos
pero si esto os parece algo ya
escandaloso esperar a ver lo que
hicieron en 1966 en la mismísima ciudad
de nueva york en ese año de 1966
tuvieron lugar varios experimentos con
la bacteria bacillus subtilis en el
metro de nueva york durante las horas
más concurridas en este caso los
experimentos consistían en lanzar
bombillas llenas de bacterias a las vías
a los propios trenes oa conductos de
respiración para comprobar cuánto se
podría expandir un ataque biológico real
si el metro fuera un objetivo
estas bombillas al romperse liberaban
millones de bacterias al aire que en
muchos casos entraron dentro de los
trenes y fueron transportadas kilómetros
y kilómetros por el subsuelo de la
ciudad el estudio determinó que si un
ataque biológico tuviera el metro de
nueva york como objetivo millones de
personas estarían expuestas a enfermar y
de esa forma la expansión del ataque
podría alcanzar la mayor parte de la
ciudad
si lo habéis escuchado bien pruebas
reales con cargas bacteriológicas en el
metro de la ciudad de nueva york
sorprendidos pues amigos igual de
impresionados debieron de quedarse en el
ayuntamiento de nueva york- porque lejos
de avisar las autoridades locales no fue
hasta el año 1980 cuando el consistorio
neoyorquino tuvo conocimiento de estos
simulacros con bacterias en su propia
ciudad
ahora bien seguro que alguno de vosotros
estará pensando vale a ver todo esto es
terrible y quizás reprobable pero
vayamos al grano han mejorado al menos
todos estos ejercicios la capacidad de
eeuu para enfrentarse a un ataque
biológico como de preparado está el país
y el mundo a día de hoy es posible una
amenaza global por un ataque de estas
características pues atentos
[Música]
un golpe de realidad a pesar de todo
bueno si pensáis que todos estos
experimentos que hemos visto han hecho
que los eeuu estén realmente preparados
a día de hoy para hacer frente a un
ataque biológico de verdad estáis muy
pero que muy equivocados al menos eso es
lo que aseguran muchos expertos en bio
defensa de eeuu escuchado la cuestión es
que no estamos totalmente preparados si
tuviéramos un ataque e incluso si
tuviésemos el tratamiento o la vacuna
que todo el mundo necesitara no tenemos
la capacidad para hacerla llegar a los
330 millones de estadounidenses
funcionarios del gobierno de eeuu no
autorizado para hablar públicamente en
declaraciones a políticos ahora bien
cómo es posible que un país que invierte
cada año 6.000 millones de dólares en
bio defensa no esté preparado para un
ataque biológico
[Música]
pues bien para entenderlo vamos a
ponernos un ejemplo con la viruela una
mortal enfermedad producida por el bario
la virus un virus que ya ha sido
erradicado en la naturaleza pero que se
conserva en laboratorios sobre todo en
laboratorios norteamericanos y rusos
veréis si de repente se liberas el virus
en una ciudad ya afuera de forma
accidental o intencionada su expansión
inicial sería prácticamente imposible de
detectar y detener ya que entre el
ataque y los primeros síntomas pasarían
varios días durante los cuales el virus
estaría campando a sus anchas y entonces
cuando por fin te das cuenta de que se
ha producido un ataque biológico puedes
tener ya cientos y cientos miles de
personas infectadas personas que de
repente se convertirían en auténticas
armas biológicas por sí mismas ellas
mismas sin quererlo propagan el virus y
contagian a muchísimas más personas
pues bien para que os hagáis una idea
actualmente los eeuu tienen un stock de
algo más de 15 millones de unidades de
la vacuna contra la viruela vacunas
prácticamente listas para usarse en
cualquier momento pero realmente esto
protegería de un eventual ataque
biológico
pues amigos lo cierto es que no están
nada pero que nada claro
entre lo que se tardaría en detectar el
virus poner en marcha una campaña masiva
de vacunación en la ciudad o región
afectada y vacunar a todos sus
habitantes pasaría tiempo por supuesto
durante ese periodo el número de
contagios no dejaría de crecer esta
forma decenas tal vez cientos de miles
de personas se contagiarían como
consecuencia del ataque biológico antes
de que las medidas de protección
empezarán a funcionar además en un mundo
cada vez más interconectado sería
cuestión de días que el virus se
expandiera por todo el país e incluso
por todo el mundo
y claro vamos a ver cómo hay poco más de
15 millones de vacunas disponibles en
los estados unidos el país ojo con
mayores reservas del mundo pues apenas
podrían vacunarse a poco más del 7 por
ciento de la población
y no sólo el esto que es el problema es
que además de ese stock tan solo
estarían disponibles para su uso
inmediato es decir para su uso en
cuestión de días 90.000 dosis tan sólo
90.000 dosis
y la situación a nivel internacional no
es mejor para que os hagáis una idea se
calcula que en todo el mundo hay 60
millones de dosis más en stock así que
imaginémonos que como consecuencia de un
ataque biológico o un accidente se
produjera un brote global sería todo un
escarnio
[Música]
y si además tenemos en cuenta que la
interconexión entre territorios y países
es ahora infinitamente mayor que cuando
se radicó el brote en su estado natural
el resultado podría suponer realmente
toda una amenaza para la humanidad lo
que os voy a contar el sars coronavirus
2 ha sido un buen ejemplo de la
capacidad que tiene un virus para
propagarse hoy en día pero dejando este
tema tan turbio un lado hay otra
cuestión que preocupa tanto más a los
expertos en bioseguridad estoy hablando
de la simplicidad y el abaratamiento de
la capacidad para evitar genéticamente
patógenos como bacterias y virus
y es que veréis en los últimos años se
ha avanzado a pasos de gigante en esta
materia gracias a un nuevo método de
edición genética llamado crease percas 9
[Música]
una técnica que permite editar genes de
forma mucho más precisa rápida y también
barata que la tecnología de visión
genética que existía hasta hace unos
pocos años
la técnica consiste fundamentalmente en
usar una enzima llamada 9 para cortar el
hilo la secuencia de adn donde tú
quieras dándote de esa forma la
posibilidad de introducir nuevo material
genético en ese espacio que queda vacío
material que puede pertenecer a otra
bacteria o virus completamente distintos
de tal modo que se puedan añadir o
eliminar características de forma
artificial
sería algo así como si cogemos unos
antiguos pantalones en los que ya no
entramos cortaremos la tela y metiéramos
una pieza entre medias para hacerlos más
grandes sólo que esa tela puede ser de
otra prenda completamente diferente y
con características distintas
pues bien este sistema ha permitido
abaratar hasta un coste de poco más de
tres mil dólares de media operaciones de
este tipo operaciones que con las
técnicas antiguas costaba mucho más
vamos que ni presupuestos militares de
cientos de miles de millones ni cientos
de caja ni flotas de drones o
portaaviones tan sólo un laboratorio y
una pequeña inversión para crear el caos
y ojo no sólo es una cuestión de coste
está técnica también ha permitido
abreviar el proceso de unos 18 meses a
poco más de tres semanas tres semanas
[Música]
es algo que desde el punto de vista de
la biomedicina ha sido toda una
revolución una revolución con resultados
muy positivos
por ejemplo ha permitido abaratar y
simplificar la modificación de genomas
de plantas para hacerlas resistentes a
las plagas y bacterias y de ese modo
garantizar la seguridad alimentaria en
muchos países pobres que sufren
constantemente este tipo de desastres
sin embargo a pesar de que la existencia
del christopher kas 9 es sin lugar a
dudas positiva lo que realmente inquieta
a los expertos en bioseguridad es que
podría pasar si este sistema de edición
genética es utilizado a niveles
avanzados por las personas equivocadas
sino un país o incluso una organización
terrorista utilizará en secreto este
método para crear bacterias o virus
modificados genéticamente para hacerlos
más resistentes más letales o más
contagiosos con el fin de usarlos como
armas biológicas podríamos estar ante un
reto para la bioseguridad de magnitudes
estratosféricas
y es que a pesar de que la edición de
genomas en virus o bacterias no es una
tarea nada sencilla el cris percas 9 ha
simplificado y ha abaratado el proceso
respecto a las técnicas antiguas por eso
resulta fundamental monitorizar de cerca
quién utiliza estas técnicas y para qué
y hoy por hoy si algo nos ha enseñado la
actual pandemia de coronavirus es que
hasta los países supuestamente mejor
preparados en bioseguridad pueden sufrir
consecuencias catastróficas
precisamente por eso muchos nos
preguntamos podría ser el mundo hoy más
vulnerable que nunca a las amenazas
biológicas qué medidas deberían tomarse
para tratar de controlar esta amenaza
creéis que vuestro país podría vencer en
un ataque biológico a gran escala como
siempre nuestras son las preguntas y
vuestras las respuestas dejadnos vuestra
opinión por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y ya sabéis si este vídeo se
resulta interesante no olvides darle al
botón de like una vez más muchas gracias
por estar ahí un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]
mis queridos
a marín se realizan esos narcos tontería